peut rien changer
sans un peu indisposé des gens il s'agit
de le faire de la meilleure manière
possible c'était en 2016 andré arthur
tentait une ultime retour à la radio de
québec un premier temps du bout des
lèvres d'éviter les dérapages
moins de deux ans plus tard il perdait
son micro dans la foulée de propos jugés
homophobes
tu ne contrôlait pas ouverture trop fait
trop beau et trop talentueuse promet tel
qualificatif de votre choix 20 minutes
20 secondes après 8 heures à l'antenne
dossier hrc si c'est dans les années 80
qu'andré arthur atteint des sommets de
popularité à l'antenne de chrc son style
sans compromis et sa fameuse tribune
téléphonique en font un favori des
auditeurs
selon alain dufresne andré arthur a
rompu avec le temps plus formelle des
animateurs de l'époque arthur s'appuyait
aussi sur ses connaissances quasi
encyclopédique de l'histoire et de
l'actualité
arthur était doté de nos mémoires
absolument atomique c'est incroyable
comment il a su
mémoriser autant de fer sur autant
d'événements avec autant de précision
mais les controverses et les excès de
langage ne sont jamais loin avec arthur
moi je vais chez lui sur 124 cap
japonaise
jeu au fil de sa carrière il sera
poursuivi des dizaines de fois en 2003
l'ex-animateur de radio robert gillet
intente une poursuite de 3 millions de
dollars pour diffamation
avant d'accepter une entente à l'amiable
en 2006 andré hatz eut réussi le tour de
force de se faire élire comme
indépendants au parlement fédéral réélu
en 2008 il sera finalement emporté par
la vague orange de 2011 qui voit le npd
gagné 59 sièges au québec
merci d'avoir servi bonrepaux
tout au long de sa carrière andré arthur
n'aura laissé personne indifférent
ici olivier lemieux radio canada québec